today's episode of congratulations is
brought to you by square cash it's great
everyone is switching to this ash it is
that people coming up to me I'm like oh
I got square cash because it's the best
way to pay people back most payments can
be deposited into your bank in seconds
and if you use other apps to pay people
a CUDA download the free square cash app
for iOS or Android and do it now before
the episode starts hi babies what's up
is everybody here babies
roll call if you're here say I put your
hand up in your car or your a cubicle
and be like I'm here it's episode 28
dude we're getting close to the episode
30 which is the 30-year anniversary of
this podcast even though it's not we're
gonna you know I mean it's we're coming
to you live from Los Angeles now so far
we broadcast the show in Los Angeles
we've done it in Toronto and I think
that's it so we're international babies
everybody's been really showing a lot of
love with the with the what do you call
it merged and the everyone's wearing
their shirts and I've been retweeting
some eeeh people are trying to get to
elder status we're not you know nobody's
been elders status yet but you know
we're gonna we're gonna figure that out
and and so now we're [ __ ] chillin in
LA I'm going to Nashville this week I
can't wait to go to Nashville I love it
I added shows there go to Chris D'Elia
calm for tickets in Nashville and also
New Jersey and also
Jerzy I'm gonna be there a number be in
New Jersey and oviya it's Jersey I'm
gonna walk around be like they use guys
I'm gonna be doing that kind of stuff
um let me say I use guys and all that
kind of [ __ ] and so I was at the Comedy
Store last night and dude there were so
many people I thought this was kind of
ending but there were so many people
vaping dude the it's not better than
smoking I'd rather have somebody smoke
and blow it in my face that someone
anywhere in the room vaping it's like so
[ __ ] goddamn obnoxious these [ __ ]
plumes of smoke have you ever like
there's no other way to describe it but
it's a [ __ ] plume of smoke dude I
swear to god somebody was vaping from
around the corner at the Comedy Store
and I thought the devil was going to
peer around there was so much smoke
wafting from inside from outside of the
[ __ ] thing and then and it still
smells like [ __ ] strawberry or like
Cinnabon go [ __ ] yourself man dude make
it smoke oh it's smoke make it smell
like smoke
why do I need it to smell like the most
beautiful [ __ ] dude oh dude are you
smoking an orchid no it's a [ __ ] vape
don't call it a pen can write with it
dude are you the devil you literally
smoke
if you smoke vape there are there is
about two to three point five seconds
where you can't see the person's face
because a plume of Devil's playground is
in front of their face
and I don't like vape smoke and there
are also like vape Olympics or some
[ __ ] or like vape trick two words I
never want to see together vape trick
they do tricks like I I don't even want
it a guy was if a guy does a cigarette
and does like a and does O's like unless
you you're holding a cat and you're an
evil villain but like these people who
can [ __ ] do big O's and like vape and
like then shoot it [ __ ] oh through
another oh and then a line through a
[ __ ] eat hey man study instead of
doing that be the president you know
this guys can do so many vape tricks
google that some of this [ __ ] they have
millions of hits don't do that
be the president and also every trick is
just really an oh it's not like you're
doing you can't make a [ __ ] horsey
out of it you're doing OHS you're making
a bunch of OHS and you're making a no go
through another oh and that's it that's
it and it's cool I never want to be good
at something this is what breakdancing
is like to me I never want to be good at
something where we're the cool we're
where this is the reaction everyone gets
oh that's like I know I don't dress like
when you dress up for Halloween if you
really do the outfit if you like are the
guy who's like went all out and spent
the money or even [ __ ] worse didn't
spend the money and did it at home
because you're being thrifty and then
you get to the party and this is the
reaction you get uh-oh you work so hard
for that reaction dude
definition of a CUDA you worked so hard
I mean this [ __ ] takes hours and these
guys are doing vape tricks and this is
the response uh-oh oh [ __ ] CUDA
god they're dumb and it's always white
guys dude it's always white guys that do
the vape tricks you know why cuz don't
have real issues to think about
that's why cuz they don't have real
issues to think about it's [ __ ] white
guys named Danny and they [ __ ] vape
and they're just like in their mom's
basement and their mom's up up in the
kitchen like dinner's ready and he's
like yeah no I know but hold on dude
trying to get owes vape [ __ ] smoke
coming up from inside the kitchen are
you vaping again and this is how you
should respond yes I'm vaping again
because that's how much smoke if you
have that much smoke around you you need
to sound like this it's true dude you
need to sound like this if you if you're
at the comedy store and you're like hold
on I gotta go vape and how about people
who vape it inside like it's not smoking
I'll fight you when they're like dude if
you vape and you don't sound like this
your meter it's a missed opportunity
dude do you know how much [ __ ] [ __ ]
you could get if you vape and also sound
like this if you'll excuse me for a
second I have got to go and then do that
tilt your head back and scream laugh so
annoying dude excuse me for a minute I
have got to go make sure the outside
patio smelling orchids excuse me for a
minute
I have got to go sir I've got to go make
sure that the outside parking lot of
this DMV smells like strawberry cinnamon
[Laughter]
who is that guy I own I don't know I
only see a plume of smoke but he
definitely has scales oh no it's just a
guy with a flat build brim Kota
oh it's just a guy named Danny say uh do
you have scales and a tail no don't have
that much smoke round yet dude do you
have tails and claws and wings and
yellow eyes No
then don't have that much smoke round
Jeff are you a dragon in [ __ ] G ot
know put the vape pen in the sewer get a
cigarette [ __ ] jump off a building do
a vape trick this what you do go all the
way up to the highest building take your
vape pen blow a [ __ ] nice big o
downward and then jump through it okay
and then when you jump through it go
like this it sure was fun while it
lasted it sure was fun while it lasted
it sure was fun while it lasted that's
what it should be [ __ ] vaping [ __ ]
vaping and then he would [ __ ] have a
funeral and it would be like here lies
Danny obviously the the priest here lies
Danny obviously he vaped and it was
obvious because his name was Danny will
forever miss his flat brimmed hats and
his o's he would make until he one day
jumped through his final Oh of smoke
he's definitely in Hell now and then it
devil's like finally nice to meet
someone as smoky as me hello Danny
and then he's like hello why do you
smell like strawberry cinnamon because
there's something unethical of a thing
dude
so don't vape but has anyone ever vaped
if they did have any
one without tattoos ever vaped though
that's what I want to know has anyone
ever vaped and not had tattoos no it's
no this period period that's hasn't
worked also dude I don't think posts
mates the [ __ ] delivery post mates is
everywhere but it's in big cities it's
like in either in in if they sent
[ __ ] food everywhere use an app you
can get food delivered
I swear to God hey stops text in me post
mates these [ __ ] 401 5 numbers do it
every [ __ ] time it's like I got the
app I can check the app when the [ __ ]
people are coming to track track your
delivery yeah ok track the delivery so
I'm looking at the guy driving on my
[ __ ] house or wherever I am and it
keeps driving and I see him and then
every time from post mates I get a text
your post mate Robert is arriving now
and we'll wait up to five minutes what
happens after the five minutes what does
he leave with my food then what [ __ ]
that
leave it or [ __ ] or just put it on
the [ __ ] thing dude on the front
porch but it's always so annoying
and then another hi Chris this is Stacey
with post mates I just picked up your
order and I'm on my way like I give a
[ __ ] dude I can see it in the app and
then for15 always with a different four
one five number how many god damn four
one five numbers do they have and then
this is the one I got your post mate
missus is arriving now and we'll wait up
to five minutes missus hey pick a name
pick a name what do you are you a hooker
your post mates and post mates missus
madam
figure it out don't text me and also I
want to open up the app I want to open
up the map on her I don't have my
notifications on don't have my
notifications on for the reason so I
don't want texts say in the [ __ ]
whenever vaped without a tattoo that's
what I want to know tweet me if you have
but you haven't do it I was at the car I
was at the coffee bean the other day
there's this crazy dude that's that's uh
what do you call it it put the crazy guy
he's the crazy guy that's always there
at the coffee bean and I had a
conversation with him and he always like
tries to ask me questions I don't even
know if he's really that crazy or what
or just kind of like silly but he's
older I thought he was homeless but he's
always getting like expensive [ __ ]
drinks like the $5 whipped cream drinks
and he's got a wedding ring on but he
comes up to me and he's like oh no he
didn't even come up to me he's like far
away from the patio nieces who Chris
it's a guy did the funky chicken dance
you know I posted it he says hey Cruz
and that I said yo what's up and he says
what if Will Ferrell asked you to work
with him and I said what do you mean
what if he said would you do it and I
said yeah and he goes like this oh I
know what is it about crazy people that
just like I guess he just felt like you
wanted to talk or some [ __ ] what the
question what if Will Ferrell like it
was like a [ __ ] like I I I like if
you're gonna ask a question I want you
to be specific about it
you know like hey would you want to work
with Will Ferrell like that's the
question but when he said what if Will
Ferrell asked your work with him I
looked at him and I said I think I said
what would happen or some I don't
remember I don't know I actually don't
want to [ __ ] talk about this I don't
give a [ __ ] it's making me like it's
making me think about like what is that
guy's homey I think he said he was
married for some reason I feel like he's
got an Asian wife and I and I feel like
he told me that once but for some reason
I imagine he goes home and just like is
so ruthless to her
and so [ __ ] got a $5 rate he gets up
you know how much this is he comes out
what it's $5 he's holding a perfect
purple drink oh yeah yeah they're so
expensive
yeah he always wears shorts and he has
his dog with him and his dog [ __ ]
like he's so shitty like somebody walked
behind the dog like it's not like
[ __ ] cute barking you're like oh god
damn it keep your dog at home dude it's
all wrinkly faced and it's not a dog
that should be wrinkly faced it's like
it's a dog that is like a dog that is
like a sweet dog that should have
[ __ ] that just has like fallen on
hard times and like if a person or a dog
walks by it [ __ ] does that [ __ ] to
her and you're like no don't have your
dog in public and his dog or him smells
like [ __ ] and I don't know which one it
is but yeah dude my dogs barking in the
back dude I got my dogs groomed and
they're so cute now and I forgot they
were that cute
I like fell in love with them again more
like they both are little bitch-ass
[ __ ] like one is skinny and
like a boy and the other ones like fat
and insecure and like a kid kind of like
a fat [ __ ] kid you know but the other
ones like the teen boy em and like
that's how he looks at me you know but
it's so cute dude by the way I almost
lost them like they they got out and I
lost them for like hours and when I got
them back I [ __ ] realized how much I
loved them it's crazy man I didn't know
how much I loved my dogs because they're
just
dogs like and they're not humans you
know but like when I almost lost them
I [ __ ] didn't know what to do
and I started thinking about what life
would be like without them and then when
I got [ __ ] back to my house because I
kept on coming back to my house after
like while I was looking for them and
they weren't there and I imagined like
coyotes eating them or some [ __ ] but it
was really cute because they left
together and then they came back
together which is like amazing they were
gone for hours and then they came back
together was like they had a little
adventure like they were in a children's
book or some [ __ ] like salmon butters
just [ __ ] were like like the show was
cold like the book is called the gate
was open and like salmon butters are
like salmon butters noticed that the
gates open and they leave and they go on
an adventure and who knows who they met
or what kind of animals they [ __ ]
came into contact with hmm they probably
just [ __ ] chilled out and explore and
it's really cute to think about them
exploring together like but then I was
worried that maybe they would get killed
but then I was like as I thought like
maybe I'll never see them again I was
like you know what they [ __ ] wanted
to leave so I found some solace in that
like they they was their choice you know
like I know they're just dogs and they
don't know better but they saw that gate
open and they were like you know what
let's go [ __ ] take a hike and see
what the hell's out there maybe that's
what they needed maybe it was like the
end of [ __ ] Point Break right we're
like Patrick Swayze is like just let me
get one last wave one last ride or
whatever the [ __ ] he says and then he
goes out there you know he's gonna die
and you don't see him ever again but
that's what my dogs did basically and I
was count of Reeves on my house just
like you gotta do what you gotta do
whoahhh and then I just
because I saw him go because I looked on
the security camera they just [ __ ]
trotted out one boy and one little one
teen just [ __ ] took a little right
and then took a [ __ ] hook left hook
to left and they both went left and yeah
it was [ __ ] wild to me though man I
would've had to change my whole act my
whole act is about my dogs now
and I was like imagining what if I had
to do it now I couldn't I can't [ __ ]
talk about I would have had to [ __ ]
talk because I talk [ __ ] about my dogs
on stage and I wouldn't I would have
[ __ ] cried you know getting surreal
don't mean to get it surreal it's
supposed to be a comedy podcast oops
but dude now I look at them and in like
a different light and then they got
groomed now they look even cuter and now
I see them and like I feel it in my
heart dude like it's all [ __ ] up I
don't know if I like it like I guess
that's what like dude like when I want
you don't understand when I watch movies
like or ozark we're like I'm gonna watch
the Noah's Ark which is great by the way
but like Jason Bateman's got this family
and like he's in trouble with it I'm not
gonna ruin it but he's in trouble with
the the drug cartel and he's like I'll
kill your whole [ __ ] family if you
don't do what I say and I'm like every
time I see [ __ ] like that on TV like
movies like there's so many movies about
that I think man thank God I don't have
kids like that's what I think I
literally think like I'll [ __ ] thank
God I have no kids but like I don't even
go far enough to think oh well but
that's never gonna happen to me because
I don't know anyone who even knows the
drug cartel but like I literally think
ah good thing I [ __ ] decided to not
have kids just in case the drug cartel
comes after me and wants to kill my
whole family they can't get me like that
but then like I feel like like I think
about my dogs which is like those
kids but I have dogs like but like if
somebody was like I'm gonna kill your
dog what's it worth to you I'd be like 4
grand maybe like gimme 6 and I'd be like
just kill my dogs but then I think about
the money I spent on other [ __ ] and it's
like maybe I would up that price a
little bit but like you know but now
that there I feel feel what it felt like
when I lost them and also they got
groomed and they look like real handsome
boys I'm like ah for [ __ ] sake I'm
falling in love now I know it's been six
years they're six but like I just
realized that I fell in love with these
[ __ ] dogs
now because I almost lost them it's like
you know when people say you don't
realize realize what you have till it's
gone it was gone I realized what I have
now love them heart is full so I like
when my heart's full no because then the
[ __ ] drug cartel can come after you
dude if your hearts full the [ __ ]
drug cartel can come after you but they
can't if it's not if you don't give a
[ __ ] in you're a sociopath the drug
cartel can't come after you don't give a
[ __ ] they come after you don't care take
me man take me but if you have kids the
drug cartel can come after you if your
heart is full the [ __ ] drug cartel
can they can get you dude humans you
know that's how we are I was watching
planet Earth and I was watching like
these uh snow leopards like they a Snow
Leopard has a [ __ ] kid Snow Leopard
and then the and then they look after
the kid Snow Leopard for like a year and
then they're like the moms like Celia
and then they leave and they're lonely
creatures and they never [ __ ] see MA
ever again they just piss on rocks and
smell each other everytime they walk by
that's what I that's what humans need to
do that's what we should do because
that's what snow leopards do they have a
kid Snow Leopard and then the kid Snow
Leopard is born and they take care of
the kids in a leopard for a little while
and then the mom one day is just like
you know what saya the [ __ ] Nara
and leaves and then just starts pissing
on rocks everywhere and then the kids
know
bird walks up to the rock is like ah
that's my mom man hey I remember her and
then leaves that's what humans need to
do that's what we need to do do it we
need to have a kid chill out for like
five six years until the kids 6:00 and
then be like see you later Tom or
[ __ ] Danny don't vape and then leave
you with some parting words and then go
a piss on [ __ ] Rite Aid's and Whole
Foods is and then the kid when it gets
eight nine crosses through that whole
foods and it's like oh [ __ ] that's my
dad anyway you know because if it's not
like that then dude you care so much
about your [ __ ] kids and the drug
cartel can come after you you want to be
strong-armed by the [ __ ] drug cartel
have kids do it that's all I'm saying
you want somebody you want to be under
someone's thumb have a boy you want to
be under someone's [ __ ] thumb have a
daughter dude have a wife you care about
I'm single no kids smooth sailing from
here man what the [ __ ] a drug cartel
gonna do that's all I'm saying dude
it's fear I guess I mean mmm you know
you're not supposed to live like I you
know I mean that's not why I don't well
I know I don't have kids react because
I'm scared I guess I'm I have fear but
not because the drug cartels gonna come
after me but because you know of all the
other responsibilities and [ __ ] like
that um but I don't know I I didn't mean
to get all [ __ ] turn this into a dr.
Phil show man and be all serious and
[ __ ] but like will you don't have kids
cuz you're scared you don't have kids
cuz you're scared I don't know I guess
my buddy said that as soon as you have a
kid you would look like he said that
when he had a kid as soon as it came out
of his wife he realized he would like
lay down in front of a car and let the
car run him over so his kid could live
how crazy is that the kid just came out
to already love something that much the
[ __ ] it just came out the kid just came
out and you're like I would kill myself
so that thing could live ah what what if
it's not that good you know I was pretty
damn excited for the jay-z album I only
listened to it like once like you know
or when people whenever they see a movie
right when it comes out and they're like
that's the best move ever seen dude
somebody once told me that transformers
was the best movie they ever saw and
they seriously said it and I couldn't
believe it and I got and I was like I
said he said yo I saw this new dude he
said I saw that you know is that the ha
ha Cafe was doing stand-up afterwards
and one of the convenience was like dude
I saw I saw transformers was like oh
yeah I was he said is the best movie
ever seen I said what he said it really
was the best movie I've ever seen and he
meant it and I said oh really why and he
said it was just amazing do it and made
me cry it was awesome and I thought well
I can't ever trust this guy ever in the
[ __ ] world
imagine thinking transfer I mean I'm not
even saying so bad yeah I did I I don't
even know if I saw it it's not bad maybe
it's good or whatever but thinking that
it's the best movie ever made
hey what oh well no no no no you know
why because it's about robots no best
movie ever made is about robots and no
best movie ever made is about robots in
disguise
ok also they're not in disguise they're
still robots they're [ __ ] car cars
that's kind of a robot in a way but yeah
I don't have kids in like I don't maybe
I'm missing out on [ __ ] I guess like
building sandcastles at the beach but I
don't want to do that [ __ ] maybe if I
had kids I'd want to do that [ __ ] but I
don't want it dude by the way
sandcastles I saw like a page on
Instagram hey some like artistic
sandcastles that's another thing imagine
spending that much time on [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden a wave comes
and wipes it away or you got to leave
and then you come back the next day and
it's half broken I mean you're doing
sandcastles he's spending the whole day
doing a nice sandcastle do something
else I mean I don't know if it's fun but
like the wait I don't like to do [ __ ]
that's just gonna [ __ ] be fleet
that's why I don't like to cook because
you just eat it and then it's gone and
you [ __ ] it out you [ __ ] it out dude
you're gonna spend [ __ ] eight hours
cooking and keeping it and soaking it
and heating it and then you ultimately
[ __ ] it out it's not worth it I'll go
pick up my food and eat it and then [ __ ]
it out that's how I think though how am
I gonna cook a bunch of food and then
just give it to people that come over to
eat who a lot of them I like but then
you [ __ ] it out some of the people I bet
you don't even like at your [ __ ] you
invite people over for like a dinner
you're like ah but he's gonna bring his
I don't like his [ __ ] wife whatever
and then she comes and you worked so
hard and then she shits out your
creation rude [ __ ] up not worth snot
worth now look it's free [ __ ]
you can [ __ ] cook and have your
enemy's [ __ ] out your art it's free
conch but if you do it well I don't want
to say turn round in that that's not
fair we got to eat and I love good food
but if you do it you work for United
turn round everyone get United in
turning round texture you heard about
this it's awesome never stopped in front
of a newsstand full of beautiful
magazine covers to pick up the latest
issue of bone Appetit or wired or people
and but and I do this a lot because the
covers are very nice and looking good
looking and colorful and you're like wow
that's really cool I want to get one but
then he can't decide which one you want
to take home well now you don't have to
with the texture app you get access to
your favorite magazines in your tablet
or phone it's like having a newsstand in
your pocket why would you buy one
magazine
what do you weirdo the texture app has
gone beyond delivering just the magazine
itself they've made it easy to find and
enjoy the articles you want to read with
daily recommendations exclusive
interactive features videos and more
texture makes magazines easy you ever
heard of over choice that's what you are
standing in front of the magazine rack
you don't have to do that anymore
there's so many great ones out there on
the texture app anyway you don't have to
go anywhere to look Hollywood Reporter
Esquire time
Forbes Vanity Fair I mean the list goes
on
texture is searchable so you can mark
what you like check out back issues view
bonus video content and they even curate
articles and magazines just for you or
whoever you're given the texture to this
you know this year texture is normally
not
a month and you get over 200 magazines
but if you sign up now at texture comm /
congrats you get a 14-day free trial
why subscribe to a couple magazines when
you can have all of them on your
smartphone or tablet all the time for
way less right now texture is offering
my listeners of 14-day free trial when
you go to texture calm Congrats that's
14 days to try texture for free when you
go to texture calm Congrats texture calm
Congrats blink kissed my new fave I like
knowing stuff so I don't like to sound
because I don't like to sound like in
like an idiot you got to know things and
a lot of us let's face it are idiots
okay and we don't know things I like to
read but I don't want to read a book
that's 2500 pages okay I read The
Fountainhead once took a year and a half
all right oh really
Howard Roark stands on the top of a
cliff naked that was the first sentence
finished the last sentence of the book
year and a half later I'm introducing
the blinka stap over two thousand of the
best-selling non-fiction books
transformed into powerful packs you can
read or listen to in just 15 minutes you
want to be knowledgeable without wasting
time blink Asst
you can feast your mind on the key ideas
from the top best-selling non-fiction
books like how to stop worrying and
start living the 4-hour workweek and
Rich Dad Poor Dad if you're just reading
you'll get through maybe one book a week
if you're me one book every 12 years but
with the blinka stap you can get the key
insights from two to three books on your
way home on your way home
blink Asst gives you more knowledge and
less time you get big ideas and small
packages now that's a cute thing to say
but I mean it learn the essential ideas
from the best books
in your field covering topics like
productivity business science
self-improvement Plus you can uncover
subjects you never knew you loved Forbes
BuzzFeed the New York Times and life
hacker
are all talking about blankets they were
chosen in Apple and Google's best
selection for two years and the app is
used by over 2 million users come on
come be your best blankets help you by
getting better to form in less time you
ever imagined
right now Linkous has a special offer
just for our audience go to blink is
calm blink cast calm / Congrats right
now to start a free trial or get three
months off your yearly plan when you
join today that's blinking spelled bli
NK ist blink it's calm / Congrats to you
start your free trial or get three
months off your yearly plan blink is
calm Congrats so don't be an idiot you
know it's only nonfiction and it's the
best that's what you should read by the
way when I read this is not the ad
anymore but when I read fiction you know
what I mean I don't know it makes me
feel like I'm just like I can think on
my own how [ __ ] narrow mind is is
that you know but I could think known I
like to think a crazy [ __ ] I want to
think of lizards taking over the world
I don't need to buy a book about that
[ __ ] I can make the lizards do whatever
I want my head I'm gonna let some
[ __ ] betta tell me how a [ __ ]
lizard takes over the world now I want
to know how aliens take over the world
oh then I don't know how about I do this
think about it make my mind do the work
nonfiction though is awesome then you
get to read about stuff and real things
that happen and then you get to say
stuff
what did I do the other day I said
something the other day that was smart
because I read something in hours I and
afterwards I was like a [ __ ] read
about that [ __ ] now I'm smart what the
hell was this I only remember what it is
now so cool
so cool that's pretty cool that I'm a
[ __ ] idiot that's the problem
I don't
retain [ __ ] you know someone to be like
65% of Americans are and I'll hear it
and I'll be like I'll cool and then
seven [ __ ] minutes later I'll be like
what is it's it's 40% of people did what
whatever let's just get coffee hey guys
it's time for the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week so you guys
found the last one hard and I think it's
cuz well I don't even want to tell you
why I think you found it because I don't
want you to find him because but I mean
you blasted that [ __ ] calling
him CUDA mm-hm and all that [ __ ] I mean
it was funny but also you know here's
one this is the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week for me and this grows a
lot of followers I don't know what her
job is
but anyway mmm this is the caption or
should I describe the picture first here
Matt whatever here we go this is a
caption now starts with a quote but not
a famous quote this is her thinking in
her head about posting right so it says
okay this is the quote okay
caption time what the [ __ ] do WTF do I
even write would anyone even read it
does anyone even care there's plenty I
want to say but it's too scary I'm
actually get I get blood red Matt
already but maybe I'll just Google an
inspirational caption and put it there
without any context about how it applies
to me
yeah I don't know I don't want to stand
out too much I mean I do want to stand
out but blending in is a little easier
all right so this is what it is so far
it's just so ridiculous
nobody's read this far okay I'm gonna
still inside the quote by the way people
might think I'm full of it selfie with a
short surface-level caption it is
whew
that's over yeah me too okay I'm glad
it's over - oh but guess what it's not
because now comes after the quote this
is now her a caption lol did I just
described anyone yeah you described
[ __ ] saddest [ __ ] people knew you
maybe she says I know I used to think
like this so I can't be the only one now
it's nice you used to think about it but
you also thinking about it now cuz
that's what you literally wrote hmm the
jury's still out something says I know I
used to think like this so I can't be
the only one if you want to make an
impact and then in parentheses refer to
my last post as to why I prefer phrasing
it this way as to opposed to grab I know
see you won't look at the last post
because this one sucks fat [ __ ] so
anyway one of the best ways to really
show up as authentically you and connect
to the people you actually want to along
the way is to write something real is to
take something you feel and write as if
you're sharing it with a friend another
parenthesis this is two parentheses now
in one caption don't do it but this is
what you did
tip tip don't ever put a tip in your
[ __ ] anything don't ever give anyone
a tip how about okay tip :
someone once told me to make a voice
memo of what I want to write and write
it that way but take out the likes and
arms the [ __ ] dude why not everyone
takes the approach of a long caption
writing or blog writing but those who do
I bet really enjoy it and find people
who also really enjoy reading them spend
the time to find a unique way to write
create explain share images and videos
and lastly be so this is the part that
really makes you want to [ __ ] do the
you know in the movie predator when the
guy takes
knife and [ __ ] draws blood across his
chest so the predator will find him then
lastly be period be so period freakin
period you period
be so freaking you imagine somebody said
hey dude be so freakin you hey if you
say freakin to me I'm going to [ __ ] you
up the ass right up the butt dude turn
round if you say freakin turn round say
[ __ ] okay everybody knows what you're
getting at
freakin only exists because the word
[ __ ] exists okay so don't say freakin
say [ __ ] cuz we all know she right
then she writes that is the only thing
separating you from another social media
account and now I would venture to say
not really I meet people like other
people every goddamn day people remind
me of other Cudas everyday dude guess
what
there's someone just like you guess what
there are so many people just like you
that's why you forget people cuz you
forget them because they're just like
other people people forgot you too this
is sad but so true then she writes let
people get to know you let and then let
me know if this was helpful it with a
thing down to the comments ah [ __ ]
turn round dude and people just thanks
thanks didn't know what to do but now
know what to do
thanks so many followers let's look at
some of these comments somebody just
writes oh this person has a podcast
great more they'll rip me on it
somebody wrote I didn't read a single
word but I agree oh and then somebody
wrote oh okay so I forgot the the
picture is uh by the way you do a
comment like this make your bed
there's a picture of her bed
snazzy make the bed and also tuck in
your cord that got tuck in your cord
tuck in the extension cord make it bed
and then somebody comments and it's
heard you know she's [ __ ] hot chick
and and he writes somebody comments she
would ride so good disrespectful dude
it's so funny - she took so much time to
do that and then some [ __ ] [ __ ]
just writes she would ride so good
saying it to nobody didn't tag anyone
just letting whoever reads it reads it
letting me know that that girl would
ride so good like what does he know the
chicks just standing there in front of a
messy bed some guy from [ __ ] you know
let's see where he's from no guess what
doesn't have a [ __ ] thing picture for
profile to followers has two followers
and following ten people and following
not even none following her yeah square
cache have you guys gotten square cache
everyone is switching to the cache app
because it's the best way to do it you
got to pay people back this way friends
family co-workers anyone lizards sending
and receiving money is totally free and
most payments can be deposited directly
in your bank account in seconds that's
real fast
you know what seconds are it's real fast
here's how it works download the square
cache app link your debit or credit card
select an amount to send and type in a
friend's phone number or email address
to complete a payment they'll get a
notification they've just received money
that's it no gimmicks
super-easy do it square cash is better
than the other apps where the money
where you've trying to send and receive
money this isn't a social network it's
just simple
it's quick it's like sending an email
who wants to have their payments listed
in a feed dude nobody I don't I don't
people know what I'm paying for
it's not Facebook it's square cash
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now I'm gonna look at
these gamut of game the system here
congratulations pod here we go really
appreciate everybody going trying to you
know do this [ __ ] and game the system
and joining my cult which is what it is
I don't like to I don't like to I don't
like to you know I'll leave this one up
leave that one up for a sec I don't like
to uh well I have no idea what the [ __ ]
I was talking about zero idea literally
zero idea I'm 37 started talking
mid-sentence had zero idea what it was
about zero idea could have been talking
about IKEA [ __ ] baseball no clue
electronics I have no [ __ ] clue so
here we go oh yeah I got it I remembered
now it always comes back you know really
appreciate the support people are
getting the merch out there you don't
have to get the merch but it's very cool
to show your support to the podcast
everybody's [ __ ] tweeting and all
that [ __ ] very cool joining my cult
everyone's getting in Humble with my
cult I got some instructions coming but
you're being real real cool and we
haven't picked elders yet because I got
to I got to [ __ ] figure out what I
want to do with elders a lot of guys
might be asking what is an elder how do
you get to be an elder well an elder in
my cult is someone who demonstrates
above and beyond commitment to spreading
congratulations and the baby ship
I guess what you would call it you baby
spread it
bakudo let somebody know there a CUDA
it's how you takes is his step towards
being an elder letting somebody know
[Music]
they need to turn round you know taking
a video of somebody being a piece of
[ __ ] and you know like if someone's
robbing a liquor store and you videotape
it and as they're running away you say
turn round and then hashtag a
congratulations pod put it up on the
internet one step closer to becoming an
elder so you can get merch and Di's at
what at my website i guess right chris
d'elia calm thoughts okay so here we go
we're gonna game the system a little bit
and look at the congratulations pod
hashtag here's from one from lino which
is his his his profile pictures of
Denzel Washington smoking weed in the
[ __ ] training Day show and his name
is Lee know at Bambino Lee know now
there's two there's a change it now
here's the deal change it immediately
actually you should have changed already
but the reason why I change it is first
of all Bambino lino is very [ __ ]
stupid second of all it rhymes okay if
you have a handle that rhymes turn round
because that's awful Bambino lino you
cute no you're not cute change it okay
here's the tweet thoughts on NFL players
who get mad over they're mad and rating
is that a [ __ ] thing Madden rating is
like a rating I would think I don't
really know but like I guess all
football players have actual ratings in
Madden and they're upset that they don't
have high enough ratings because they
think that they're better I guess I
don't know it's very stupid who cares if
you're on a video game you made it if
I'm on a video game and I have the worst
rating if there was a video game called
comedians
and I was on there and my player rating
was bad I'd be like oh cool I'm on a
video game but this is actually
something I've wanted to talk about
somebody brought this one up right now
and I walked by one the other day and
I've done one okay this is from Danny
guy Ehrman which I don't even know it is
a spell his last name or her last name
yeah
GE I er M ay ay ay and at too many E's
just pick one II have it before the IR
after the I you don't need to guy Ehrman
your thoughts on escape rooms can we add
this to our list of good gunk for the
cult 100% dude I I walked by an escape
room the other day and there was a crowd
of white people dork in it the [ __ ] up
outside talking about their experience
on a Sunday now one had Tevas and
[ __ ] high shorts and this guy just
needed to get [ __ ] a vehicle Kareem
into his white face do it I mean this
guy was just like and then you turn the
dial the B and then you put the letters
in the PAC
gunk hey you're only the [ __ ] it's
here's the rule it's only okay to do an
escape room by yourself you go in with a
team and dork it up you got [ __ ] buck
teeth in my imagination you got buck
teeth
you're skinny fat or whatever that means
you got like some [ __ ] shirt that's
like stale blue hi shorty and Tevas and
your dork in it the [ __ ] up dude has
anybody not white ever done an escape
room how white is it to be like let's
pretend we're trapped
[ __ ] idiots real people are trapped
out there let's pretend we're trapped
let's drive over in our Prius and
pretend we're trapped and have a wizard
tell us where to [ __ ] dude I didn't
escape room once and I pretended so hard
like I had fun and then I left and
everyone was like did you have fun and I
was like you know what I didn't think I
was gonna like it
but I did well I'm telling you right now
I lied
it wasn't fun an escape room that you
can get out dude you can get out of the
escape room if you really wanted to you
didn't you don't have to do the puzzles
you can just leave you say to whoever
stand in there that works there because
there's always somebody that works there
in the room you say hey get the get me
the [ __ ] out of here dude my producers
trying to remind me I don't remember
what did I do
I used the cellphone flashlight oh yeah
I used my cell phone flashlight because
it was dark and [ __ ] somebody got mad
at me and we fought we argued like you
can't use that I'm like yeah you can
this is my phone I'm turning it on why
well cuz we're in an escape room dude
we're downtown Los Angeles escape room
we were all white was the whitest [ __ ]
ever
I'll never dude oh but on land I'm this
but in sky on this and I've from the
ceiling looking up at noon too dark good
gunk turn round dude coud escape room
coud escape room if there's anything
that a [ __ ] CUDA would do it's an
escape room come on dude you heard about
it oh you heard about it oh you heard
about it see ya
oh my god an escape I'm imagine let's
pretend we're trapped white people say
yeah you deserve you deserve some I
don't know if you do an escape room for
fun for an hour you deserve to be us
you deserve to be a slave for a week
that's what you deserve
let's look at more of these [ __ ]
hashtags I wanted to talk about that I
forgot to write that down I definitely
wanted to talk about that this week I
walked by it and I'm glad this person do
it too many E's and their names reminded
me of it really good one person writes
see a dude wearing a fedora you code it
it's true I've said that before though I
think this person actually said
something I disagree with Steve Ian's
otoni sit Dalian Steve in a Tony Italian
you know how you know it's Italian too
many syllables Ian at Tony shortened it
you're in America shorten it shorten it
or eat pizza every day this guy writes
and I disagree with it but good job I
like when people feel things though and
have passionate things I ideas about
things even if I don't agree with them
if they're like I don't like when
somebody wears [ __ ] Nikes because of
this I love Nike but you know um here we
go don't you love when people back their
car into parking spaces now I do love it
I think he's being sarcastic but I do
here's why cuz when you leave you don't
have to wait for some jackass you just
zip the [ __ ] out
zip the [ __ ] out get if you get in your
car and you [ __ ] turn it on and you
chill and you look at your phone and you
[ __ ] do this and you turn on the air
before you leave get out get out get out
mede that's immediately get out meat
anyway oh here's another here's a good
one
that dude at Kate Pierce Oh ate that's
cool that's the first name change it
I've ever seen usually it's the handle
change change it this guy's name on it
is that dude by change it
why is everybody to change it why can't
every anybody be just Dan [ __ ] Smith
thoughts on people who have instagrams
for their pets yeah dude
here's what you're gonna do if you got
an Instagram for your pet go into the
Instagram for your pet screenshot every
post then go all the way back up top
because now you're at the bottom screen
shot in the first post of your pet you
ever did you're gonna want to scroll all
the way to the top you kind of want to
hit that upper right thing you're gonna
want to deactivate your account then
what you're gonna wanna do is go to your
account your Instagram account then
you're gonna want to take all those
pictures you screenshot it and you're
going to want to upload those on to your
account and then you're going to have
that as your only account okay nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your dog enough to go
check your dog's Instagram because guess
what your dog's not posting you're
posting the dogs not posted and we know
that cuz the dogs don't have thumbs okay
now if you don't have thumbs don't have
an Instagram account now if you're a
human that doesn't have thumbs don't
have an Instagram account period that's
the rule
so anyway I think that's it dude those
are some good questions you guys are
really coming through with the good
questions yeah that's good new merch
rolling in this week restock rather will
restock and everything the Yakuza shirts
sold out in less than a day they were
gone free conch gone so go check now and
there's still some left but we're
restocking the the popular sizes like
extra large because everybody's well fat
is [ __ ] so I'm gonna have to get some
more XXL ones cuz everybody in the mid
conch fat is [ __ ] so good lots of fat
people on the sides too but mostly in
the mid conch lose anyway yeah so that's
it if you haven't downloaded the square
cash app just do it now so I don't have
to [ __ ] tell you to do it again
square cash download the free square
cash app for iOS or Android now so yeah
the merchandise and stuff is getting a
restock this week go check now guys
watch man on fire I think a lot of you
have if you haven't yet watch man on
fire and let me know what you think
that's my newest special it's really
special and important to me I'm happy
with it it's my third special thanks for
watching if you have if you haven't
check it out and then tweet me about man
on fire and rate and review the this
podcast that will be helpful this this
is you want to be an elder you got to do
all these things okay rate your review
hashtag it congratulations pod let me
know what's up I got some upcoming shows
here nashville tennessee i added too
because lots of babies out there i want
to become in hollywood california
those were sold out phoenix arizona
coming up Salt Lake City Tempe Arizona
New Brunswick New Jersey Spokane
Washington Charlotte North Carolina
Melbourne Australia Sydney Australia
Irvine California I'm also this week I'm
at in Brisbane Adelaide this is an
Australia Brisbane Adelaide and Perth
guys thanks so much
congratulations podcast you guys thank
you so much my baby's podcast 28 over
and done with see you guys later
[Music]